the US presidential hopeful Hillary
Clinton has become the latest
high-profile figure from the United
States to weigh in on the EU debate
she's followed Barack Obama's lead and
given her backing to Britain remaining
part of the European Union now the
American president has been accused of
hypocrisy by some euro skeptics after
his very public intervention over the
last few days well I'm join now by the
Labour MP took up the mother who's part
of the Britain stronger in Europe
campaign I wrote a good morning to you
miss one well it will speak about
President Obama and his right to
intervene in in are you a referendum
debate the realize that same could
backfire people don't like being told
what to do by foreign leaders well of
course that's something those who argue
for us to leave say about Barack Obama's
interventions because from their point
of view what he said wasn't welcome but
he was very clear this isn't about
instructing us on what we should do on
the twenty-third of June but as a close
ally and big friend of the United
Kingdom giving a view and I don't think
you know we can't on the one hand if you
like really embrace and almost boast
about our special relationship with the
United States and then on the other hand
when you have things like this come up
and the US president expresses a view on
what it will mean for bicha children
born say oh well we're just going to
dismiss what he said so I'm not
necessarily saying it's going to be
decisive but I think now people voting
on the twenty-third ajumma one another
what what he thinks and to be honest i'd
much rather from you remain campaigns
point view of much rather we had the
likes of barack obama and others as we
do have arguing for britain to remain in
the union Utley them you know how cake
marine lepen whose parently flying in
from France to support the breasteses
India really filled in Nigel Farage
about that but more more broadly there's
a suspicion this isn't necessarily from
people who've made up their mind either
way that some you know you guys are
connected so to speak so David Cameron's
you know Obama away in Hillary Clinton's
now joining we're just looking at the
shots of a marine one they helicopter
ferrying the President to the airport
there at Stansted before he boards Air
Force One and is heading for for Germany
a g5 sonic taking place mr. Obama will
meet Mr Cameron again
that set tomorrow but chicken Mona this
the census is that you know you're
getting the business leaders you're
getting the political leaders you've
lined them all up there you're trying to
browbeat you're trying to blackmail
people I don't think so no not at all
and what you see there and you've put a
point of view which is peddled by those
who wish us to leave which is a kind of
you know they've become conspiracy
theorists if you like there's a broad
swath of opinion of different
independent organizations who have
argued that it's best for Britain and
British people for us to stay in the
European Union and they're now telling
us that you've say got the likes of Len
McCluskey the leader the biggest union
in the country unite in cahoots with
that well-known socialist at the IMF
christine lagarde and of course the
other socialist at the CBI all of this
being orchestrated by President Obama at
the behest of lemon McCluskey's new best
friend George Osborne the Chancellor
miss checker in in number 11 Dimitri of
course that's fantasy that's ludicrous
but what you've got is a broad swath of
independent organizations abroad to rate
a foreign leaders who we respect to a
saying look we think for the point of
view of the British people this is the
best thing for you to do to remain a
member of Europe union because that's
how you keep the great in Great Britain
well you mentioned respect their let's
talk about the comments sir from the
Mayor of London Boris Johnson refer it
to mr. Obama's heritage is part Kenyan
being some of the reason he suspects mr.
Johnson suspects that he might not like
the UK and in his further quoted is
calling him weird well I think what
Boris Johnson said was disgraceful and
embarrassing I think for any Londoner to
watch our mayor of london raise the
issue of the president of the united
states ethnicity and then very publicly
have to be slapped down by that
president for doing so I think for
Londoners is an embarrassment but worse
than that is the suggestion that if you
don't particularly like colonization and
you don't think that that was a very
good thing in the past and look I'm part
Nigerian Nigeria as a former colony of
the UK I don't think a lonely anization
is terribly defensible somehow to hold
that view
means that you love Britain less or you
have less respect for the United Kingdom
that was essentially the suggestion in
what Boris Johnson said which I think a
whole swath of Britain's diaspora
communities from Commonwealth countries
have come to settle here people have got
a background like mine find deeply
offensive and I actually think what it
illustrates is this man is simply not
fit to hold the office that he clearly
aspires to which is the prime minister
of our country this kind of divisive
rhetoric is indefensible and I think you
know since this campaign has started the
EU referendum campaign has started I
think it is exposed Boris Johnson and it
has shown that he simply not fit for the
office that he aspires to take and of
course there's going to be a change in
prime minister before the general
election yeah okay and maybe sooner than
sooner than many people might expect
your leader though Jeremy Corbyn I mean
you've been Foursquare behind the
campaign since it started plenty of
people in your party asking for Jeremy
Corbyn to do more to prevent a brexit so
he's made one speech with 11 big speech
is he going to do more after the may
elections is he really going to roll the
sleeves up and get involved you spoken
to him yeah of it I have spoken to about
it he is going to do more I thought his
speech was fantastic I was very very
pleased with it and in some senses
because he's not being you know an
evangelist for the European you what you
said he wasn't wholeheartedly and local
and he wasn't at the the outset but he's
looked on balanced search what we
believe in the values that we hold dear
is a Labour Party we want to see a more
equal more democratic more environment
environmentally sustainable world he's
looked at this imbalance and come to the
you quite rightly that we can best
advance the progressive causes that we
believe in by being part of this
European club as opposed to sitting on
the sidelines working with people like
Nigel Farage marine lepen and others he
knows that if you care about the things
that we care about on the Labour Party
the best way to advance that is through
British men would you call from the
entire leadership which because you're
not now part of the entire labor
leadership
mobilize the Labor Party operation
you've got a formidable ground operation
and suisse or from the general agent
okay you lost but you get the voter
perhaps not in the places that actually
matter for you to win the general
election but you get the boat out and on
this its bulk votes you can get
particularly that young boat yeah I mean
I think you try younger voters who in
the you know in much greater numbers
voted for labor at the last general
election are going to be important but
also I mean I lead the labor campaign in
the labor in for Britain campaign in
London and if you look at the 10 most
pro-eu areas in the country five of them
are in London Lambeth souther brain
harringay and there are others like
Tower Hamlets Merton etc where we have a
huge number of people who favor our
membership but we've got to get them out
to vote that's the absolute key thing